tu che fai se mio nonno che oggi una
grandissima richiesta una nuova slime
colori giallo marrone non vede chiesto
di fare per sociale un gioco di colore
che abbiamo di più nello sly avere solo
una giusto sapete benissimo che per me è
il verde nelle slide quindi la
maledizione del verde
eppure vitale è più bar ora a chi mezzo
messo storia super divertente però se
riusciamo a fare lo slime nel mio caso
il più verde possibile nel caso di
evitare il più marrone possibile
vinciamo e sarete voi a votare chi vince
metterò la fidesz video fa il sondaggio
potrete votare servizio di invertire
questa varietà come potete vedere qui
sta un po larga perché il nostro no
magliette verdi quindi questa è una
maglietta digitale
le regole sono semplicissime ogni turno
dovremo bendarci e pescare un
ingrediente a caso e se prendiamo un
ingrediente che non è del colore del
nostro team saremmo svantaggiati se
invece il settore del nostro team saremo
avvantaggiati perché in queste
condizioni vedete il vero del marrone ma
alcuni dentro potrebbero essere di un
colore leggermente di narcos auguro
nell'acqua da fare se potrebbero
cambiare colore scorso video raggiunto i
15 mila mi piace come vi avevamo chiesto
se questo è questo video riesce a
raggiungere i 20 mila mi piace nella
prossima a san marino oro
argento sarà fantastico e super etico
quindi lasciate un bel mi piace fare
bene quanti si è tenuto un fastidioso
frutti
metteteli cavoli fatto sì che i pop corn
e gli siano ok primo turno andiamo
funzionare le nostre band e qualche
berlino che vuole partecipare prati
pratica uno scatto una bustina mi
raccomando dobbiamo far cadere la mano e
qualsiasi cosa tocchiamo dobbiamo
prenderla non possiamo sceglierlo con le
mani devo togliere la mendola ha così
preso un brasato e che si aspetta per un
marrone quello fosse trasparente dove
non bottiglia un marrone dovesse
capitare trasparenza al mediano che mai
siamo avvocato dei glitter verdi quindi
sono sicura che questi sono verdi perché
si vede sono trasparenti nato numero uno
un po trasparenti
andiamo a servo assieme ad esso ok ecco
qua i miei glitter birdie andiamo a
metterli lanus live nella colla
trasparente effettivamente sono un po
angoli sono un po trasparenti però sono
comunque berti dà il tono verdi lo
stesso vediamoli tutti per fortuna avevo
bisogno capito bene perché io li odio
questi qua albergo
perché ma vitale odia questi glitter
non so perchè non mi piacciono perchè
non mi piacciono perché mi sono provate
scaglie di vetro non lo so che ho paura
non vi piacciono ma dai più belli ma
stanno bene sono proprio riguardo si
vede benissimo brutto che vediamo di che
colore è questo olio abbronzante
speriamo che non sia marrone così vitale
svantaggiate
[Applauso]
un direttore o però chi state il
questore affrontante rovinerà la m non
ho mai provato ad aggiungere errori
approntate a monza ma si sta separando
dalla colla dimostrano però almeno lo
sta colorando un po brand book e
consistenza potrebbe avere dopo ma sto
imparando forse bisogna girarlo fatto
altre volte porta parte parte forte
forte forte ha una consistenza
autostrada è un po di colore ha già c'è
anche secondo tour mentre beve una birra
con pescato qualcosa di pesante che
penso di sapere anch'io credo sia un
bagnoschiuma che questo sia il sapone
per piatti e per il corpo fantastico
perché al cioccolato di profumeria anche
benissimo ma secondo te chi non doveva
prendere questo gioco lato sono mica
potevo prendere barrette al cioccolato
fondente oggi non so di cioccolato che
buono ma secondo me e barone davvero
dentro potrebbe essere bianco
di fatto secondo me e marrone davvero ma
qui però forse il detersivo per piatti
potrebbe rovinare lo slang potrebbe
scioglierlo non lo so cosa potrebbe fare
perché sapete che si può fare solo slam
senza colla qualcosa di te estivo però
con la colla
non so che reazione farò solo per adesso
assieme vede eccolo qua è anche un
perdonino brutto è un verde verde
pisello allora eccolo qua abbastanza
chiara come verde si confonde con la mia
parente lo stesso colore la mia paletta
ti prego non sognare lo slime non
togliere la famosa quando me non lo
scioglie
quindi la polisemia grasso speriamo che
dopo si attivi beh però non sono male
questi glitter si sta molto bene
vediamo ora quello di vita le foto che
l'hanno è giusto che strano nostra così
linda come si attiverà con questo io
vedo non vedo l'ora di mettere questo
filo al cioccolato canegrate varrone
mario ferraro non faccio breve sulla
cioccolata sotto wow profumerà anche
aperto tra il semplice buon profumo e
marrone molto chiaro e molto chiaro mi
sa che sei in vantaggio tu che
importanza secondo voi mi sembra un
verde evidenziatore il tuo invece una
sorta di marroni games marrone molto
chiaro
chiediamo frati il 3 2 1t pronto adesso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questi penso che siano dei glitter preso
dividiamo verde abbia mai via pigmento
rosso mette a terra bruciata visti forse
risulterà un po di colomba nemico quindi
tutto in più per il pigmento adesso
diventeranno entrambe vitalizzati perché
stai facendo una gallina papa ma tu sei
un cerbiatto ma come fai come un paese
inviata non so come faccia abbia trovato
scrivete nei commenti come fecero un
piatto sicuramente non fa ecco qua il
pigmento verde speriamo che lo renda
ancora più che bene
ma troppo strano accanto quello del tuo
primo slide lo verde volontario chissà
magari dopo che faccio questo spreco
tutte queste conseguenti la maledizione
del bernie mi lascerà in pace perché di
ragazzi è usato fin troppi ingredienti
verdi non li faccio più capitare
penso che magari si cominciò a piacere
il verde così ha fatto il più primo
store perdere sarà invaso tutti i verdi
perché il viaggio ma vediamo una volta
che antico se mi piace da matti magari
scopri che ti piace questa guerra è però
non è male così metallizzato e molto
carino l'effetto che vediamo poi su big
man marroncino finalmente magari
riusciamo a mettere un po di colore su
questo slide è proprio un marrone scuro
attenzione però perché si diventa rosso
infatti io sto a quadretti perdere la
salle difficilmente perde perché sono
fortunato e per ora vediamo gira si
aggira sembra molto marrone un altro
dato da non è molto marrone di non
parlare più facile più pagine con verde
guarda che sta facendo benissimo guarda
è un marrone delicato in più questo
profumo di cioccolato il meteo confronti
32 buttato pesca un tubetto di qualcosa
lo sento molto pesante queste case sono
salite veniamo sul pescato una sorta di
colorante schiumando richiamo di sesso
diverso questo perché di un marrone che
non ti dicono la cassetta di merlino
invece ho beccato con i glitter verdi
quindi fortunato andiamo mettono in rete
lo stesso troppo curioso di vedere
comunque questa cosa come trasforma non
mi piace tanto non so se è riuscito a
vedere che c'è qualcosa che gocciola
mattia il pacco lardo questa cosa
marrone a 10 così sarebbe non lo so
speriamo che l'abilità slime vediamo
puzza ok
ecco qua la mia o con le mette rata
verde
vediamo se curia un po il colore e
metterà ancora più semplici ma prometto
che leghi ma questa volta sì sono stata
fortunata pescare solo cose carine
finora quindi forse dopo andrà peggio
la maledizione del verde che mi sta
portando fortuna perché finalmente sto
scegliendo il verde sismico secondo me
the last hurrah minardo che lo sta
facendo diventare il giallo
dipietresco un palazzo si vedono solo
alcuni glitter ma il resto non si delle
cose niente 1 col prezzemolo
ora vediamo il gioco herat
vediamo quindi è un colorante o cos'è
non lo so l'invito a un po senso ma
sempre tutt'altra cosa però è marrone
quindi finalmente farò diventare il suo
plenum marrone per davvero forte e anche
troppo un errore l'altissimo che cosa si
è trasformato in marrone per fortuna non
sono forza in effetti un po strano
questo colore i commenti che colore è
questo secondo voi
mario bravi non ho capito tra gr1 no no
fermato altri perché c'è un pescatore
cosa bruttissima che non mi piace far
niente che non ti piace per niente ma
vira in meno nel cibo per più bello
oltretutto sapete benissimo che quel
club arrone sembra qualcos'altro e
quindi non vedo l'ora di vedere cosa
sembra buffa è bruttissimo clima che
hanno inventato questo play no io voglio
dire guardate sembrano dei pezzi di
biscotto sembrano dei pezzi di
cioccolato forse no sembra che tanto me
lo chiedo
sembra un ostello gustoso insieme sembra
lo metto a cui lo aggiungo dopo ecco poi
milito il caspica mai sono stata proprio
fortunata in questa folle e già sposa
nel mezzo filtro vi andiamo a mischiare
anche se non mi piace il fatto che sia
tutto verde ovviamente lo sa bene però
almeno sono stata fortunata e questa
challenge finora sembra un po buco di
troll per il mese
però ne aggiungerà il dopo aggiunto lari
altrimenti ora non si mischiano bene non
vedo l'ora di vederle ministro non si
strugge prendiamo che cosa è questa cosa
pubblico dei glitter in mi sa che un
backup prima la forma forse forse forse
rischia morali che cos'è e un altro
pigmento marrone queste marrone più
chiaro quindi forza riusciva però a
renderlo più bello
preso anche questo se parlasse a più
persone che sapevano rischiato la stessa
cosa hanno messo nero nato allora ecco
qua io metto un'altra penna di glitter
parte non so che non lo rovina
verrebbero questo brutto il resto questo
mica e questo è bello
sembrava testa un brutto te l'ho detto
sembra buco di troppo glitterato come
mettendo ok vediamo ora se il tuo
pigmento migliore tuo slime speriamo che
bel colore ed io pure ho paura dove un
po più bianco ma come di bianco perché
perché di colore youtube è più forte
quello dello slide smetto questo diventa
chiaro il vento di memoria la se
rendendo un po metallizzato almeno dai
quasi quasi mi piace io quando verbita
le non ti preoccupare perché tanto dopo
il player o fine è arrivato il momento
di attivare i nostri slime verde
verdissimo contro marrone il moralismo
prodi red
ecco qua il news live allora ovviamente
il verde verdissimo vero e metallizzato
e contanti glitter
guardate un po il colore alla fine è
uscito un verdolino chiaro e si vedono
in lizza soprattutto e la rassegna un po
di sony cyber ne vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non male su riserva sul fuoco piè tante
e il profumo sa di mela verde e di
detersivo detersivo per piatti al nome
la verde vediamo era quello di vitale
che vi dico già che se un profumo di
cioccolato e albero degli a un po io
sono per il profumo voto per vitale
[Musica]
per lucido questo per la crema
abbronzante il sito così lui sì è vero
per l'olio abbronzante e uno slide
guarda che bolle fra un sacco di rumori
che spettacolo fantastico mi preme big
bubble alla coca cola è veramente non
breve corby pro link di aster a berlino
da sbadiglia però però però io volevo
fermarmi qui ma invece devo aggiungere
[Musica]
infatti io poter evitare solo per i
rumori e per chi sa di cioccolato a
george gray adesso vediamo come diretta
aggiunge la cassetta prendiamo la
vecchietta che bella non è giusto e vero
a che cosa hai fatto berlino e adesso
che sto bene ma come la metti camerun e
plus time al dr
allora adesso sembra sempre come se sera
se abbiamo aggiunto del cioccolato in
polvere e si laza di cioccolato ma
stanno cadendo un po di mesi ha chiesto
però
questa scelta mi ha rovinato il fascista
mi ha rovinato lo slime che era
bellissimo io voto per l'italia
allora qual è il più bello il mio verde
quello marrone cacchetta di vitale
votate nel sondaggio the beach team
berga sim barra allora cosa ti pare il
sondaggio seviziati in verde o di
barrare e mi raccomando lasciati per mi
piace per vedere poi la challenge ora
contro e ora vi lasciamo con quattro
carte di criticare per vedere le nostre
altre channel
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]